HARLAN STENN: My
name is Harlan Stenn,
and I'm with Network
Time Foundation.
Network Time Foundation
is a legal entity
that can receive money and
equipment on behalf of network
time projects like
the NTP project
and a couple of PTP projects,
and three or four others.
Time isn't important
until it is.
So it goes to everything
from quality of medical care
to whether or not a
stock market trade
should have been allowed
to happen or not,
based on the time.
Your dry cleaning, in
by nine, out by five.
The list goes on
and on from there.
It's a lot of social contracts,
a lot of other things,
service-level agreements,
things like that.
Network Time Foundation
has been involved
with Google Summer of Code
since 2007, maybe 2008.
This year, we had seven
projects and students.
Two of them worked on
testing, and writing code
to test our various algorithms.
Two of them worked on
trying to decide from the
get go, how much
does the time have
to be adjusted for a clock.
And how fast does it drift away?
We had one student working
on our new general time-stamp
API, which is a way to
have actually useful time
stamps for code, two,
three, four, five.
We had one student
who cleaned up
a directory that contained a
bunch of miscellaneous files
and programs.
And then there was
a seventh student.
And that project is
currently just escaping me.
Some of the things
that we'd like
to do with Google Summer of
Code that we haven't done before
include finishing work
on some of the projects
we've started that frequently
take multiple years
and multiple sessions to finish.
We've always got
openings for students,
hopefully at the PhD
or postdoc level,
who are very good
with mathematics,
to study clock algorithms
and noise, to make
more precise clocks.
We can usually find
plenty of things to do.
[BACKGROUND APPLAUSE]
Oh that was definitely for me.
Yeah, really.
We'll take anything from
systems administration help,
webmaster email help.
We love people who can write
documentation, or to help
with social
networking and media.
We'd love to have
people who write code.
This can be anything
from understanding
the deep technical
guts of what it takes
to have time work
properly, to folks who
want to help make sure
we have a good GUI
to configure something.
So basically, if they have
a good idea, we'll take it.
And if they're
looking for ideas,
we can probably find a
whole bunch for them.
There are lots of
amazing opportunities
in a wide variety of
places, for people
who want to help volunteer
at Network Time Foundation.
We had actually two
mentors who have come back
from previous Google
Summer of Code
to help mentor current students.
And that was really wonderful.
Network Time Protocol
has been in operation
for a little over 30 years now.
It's one of the longest running
protocols on the internet.
I really enjoy helping
students explore new ideas,
and get used to what it's like
to write production-worthy code
in the real world, and to
find things that excite them
and find a way to
have it be a win-win.
Google Summer of Code
has been remarkably
wonderful to Network
Time in several ways.
We've had several projects that
have been very difficult to do.
And I can think of
two or three of them
that we've run the program
three years in a row just
to get them completed.
And we wouldn't have been
able to have completed
these projects at all if
we hadn't done the earlier
sessions where we'd
also worked on it.
And we just haven't had the
volunteers to come forward.
And I haven't had the
time to do them myself.
So Google Summer
of Code has helped
us to bring to fruition
several projects that
were just big in scope.
And it's also helped us
with a number of projects
where we just needed
somebody for a few months
and they can sit and punch
something out and focus
on it for a while.
We've had several
students who've
been involved with
Google Summer of Code
stick around with either
the Network Time Protocol
project or Network
Time Foundation,
to either continue to
do their work they've
done as volunteers, or to shift
direction into other areas
and help out the project.
And that's been really
wonderful for them and for us.
And I'm not just saying
this to kiss up either.
[LAUGHTER]